[Music]
welcome back to science click today
general relativity
what is gravitation gravitation or
gravity is a fundamental phenomenon in
the universe which tends to bring
objects closer together if the Apple
falls to the ground the moon orbits the
earth and the Earth orbits the Sun that
is all because of gravity which operates
between these objects and prevents them
from moving away one from the other
at first glance we might think that
gravitation is a force that acts by
attracting objects according to their
mass the more mass of an object the more
it pull other objects in the universe in
its direction this representation of
gravity is a force enables us to
understand the behavior of objects when
they fall or the way in which planets go
around the Sun however in reality
certain subtle indicators show that
gravitation is not really a force for
instance when we observe a satellite
falling towards the Earth if gravity was
a force it should fall straight towards
the center of the planet but when we
carry out this experiment we see that
its trajectory is slightly curved
following the direction of the rotation
of the earth another indicator is the
fact that Mercury's orbit changes
orientation with a certain speed as time
goes by if gravity was a force then we
would be able to accurately predict the
speed with which this orbit should
change however what we observe is that
the orbit changes with a slightly
different speed
[Music]
if we take into account these subtle
indicators we come to the conclusion
that gravitation is by no means of force
capturing its nature requires us to
entirely review our understanding of the
world of the entire universe as well as
of space and time this is what we call
general relativity for its elaboration
general relativity based itself almost
entirely on the equivalence principle
the equivalence principle states that
all objects fall in the same way it says
that free fall is not the action of a
force it is not an accelerated movement
of the object falling rather free fall
is the natural movement for all entities
when objects fall on earth this is
equivalent to these objects actually
being at rest while it is in reality the
ground which accelerates towards them
[Music]
contrary to our naive intuition it is
the act of falling which constitutes a
natural movement a rest position in
sorts while actually being motionless on
the surface of the earth comes down to
being in constant resistance to free
fall and constantly exerting an upward
acceleration it is for this reason that
we actually only feel our weight once we
have touched the ground during freefall
our body follows its natural movement
and it is only when touching the ground
that we feel our weight the action of
our feet putting a stop to the fall in
general relativity gravitation is thus
no longer a force
we can almost say that gravitation does
not exist that it is a sort of illusion
if entities give off the impression that
they are falling and that they attract
each other this is because they are
moving naturally being at rest but in a
universe whose geometry is curved
objects do not attract each other they
merely move about in straight lines but
they also curved space-time around them
as a result of their mass this is what
influences the trajectories of other
surrounding objects the most important
idea in general relativity is that all
objects that possess a mass distort
space-time around them to understand if
we conceptualize our universe is an
immense web a grid of space and time
then a massive object will indeed have
the effect of distorting this space-time
around it the notions of distance of
direction or even of the flow of time
are thus distorted altered by the
presence of the object naturally an
object will have a tendency to move
about in a straight line for example if
we throw an apple in the middle of
intergalactic emptiness it would
continue its trajectory in a straight
line always with the same speed but what
if we were to throw this same Apple next
to a massive object like Earth since it
is so massive earth bend space-time
around itself straight lines become
distorted curved and intertwined in the
direction of the planet as such when we
release the Apple it goes in a straight
line but since straight lines have been
distorted by the mass of the earth the
Apple gradually comes closer to the
ground
this effect is precisely what we call
gravitation when an object is very
massive it distorts the very structure
of the universe round it curving
straight lines in its direction and
consequently all the objects around it
will have a tendency to follow these
curved lines and hence get closer to the
object
to better understand let us imagine
simultaneously the following two
scenarios on the one hand two observers
are moving on a straight upward line on
a flat plane which is not a curved
surface on the other the two observers
are moving in a straight line towards
North but on the surface of the earth
which is a sphere so this time a curved
surface in the first scenario for the
flat surface the two observers will
travel in parallel straight lines in
this way they will never get closer one
to the other however in the second
situation on the surface of the earth by
walking straight our two observers will
oddly end up meeting when they reach the
North Pole although each of them has
been walking in a perfect straight line
due to the curvature of the earth and
consequently the fact that straight
lines are bent on its surface these two
people will feel like a mysterious
attraction force is making them
progressively get closer one to the
other with this example we understand
better how gravitation can emerge from
the curvature of space-time objects seem
to be attracted to each other and their
trajectory seemed to progressively meet
up but in reality this phenomenon is due
to the curvature of straight lines along
which objects move
to illustrate this peculiar phenomena
which appear in general relativity let's
focus on one fascinating object of our
universe the black hole a black hole is
a very massive object whose matter is
mostly contained in one single point we
call this central point a gravitational
singularity at this precise spot in the
universe the fabric of space-time is
distorting to infinity and modern
science is not able to understand fully
what happens there close to the
singularity the curvature of space-time
is so great that all straight lines
point in this direction here no object
can hope escaping the black hole even
for light rays or possible paths lead
towards the singularity the black hole
emits no light and neither matter nor
radiation can escape it for this reason
we see it as an entirely black sphere
outside this capture zone beyond this
limit that we call its horizon the black
hole behaves similarly to any other
object when we are close to the horizon
it is impossible to stay in stable orbit
around the black hole the distortion of
space-time is too great which renders
the trajectories of objects chaotic and
difficult to predict at this distance
however as soon as we find ourselves
sufficiently far from the horizon as is
the case for a planet or a star it is
possible to gravitate in a stable manner
around the black hole an object passing
nearby will be slightly deviated but
will still be able to escape its
attraction in particular light rays
coming from distant stars change
direction when they get close to the
black hole for this reason if we observe
a black hole face-on we can see a
distorted image of faraway stars which
are actually behind it this is what we
call gravitational lensing another
interesting phenomenon appears when the
black hole rotates on itself in the case
of a black hole in quick rotation this
will slightly pull the fabric of
space-time into the rotation an object
falling towards the black hole traveling
on a straight line will thus be deviated
according to the rotation of the black
hole this very strange effect is also
applicable to the earth whose rotation
on itself leads to a slight deviation in
the full of object finally one of the
most noteworthy phenomena is what we
call gravitational time dilation when we
find ourselves close to massive objects
like a black hole
the straight lines that we follow are
distorted not only in space but also in
mostly in time the flow of time will
therefore be altered according to the
distance to which we are from the
massive object at a great distance from
the black hole where the curvature of
space-time is almost imperceptible time
flows more or less like elsewhere
however the closer we get to the black
hole the more we notice that the flow of
time slows down for our clock close to
the horizon of black hole space-time is
so distorted that it is possible that
for each second that goes by for us a
whole year would go by for a distant
observer
in general the closer we are to a source
of gravitation in other words a massive
object like the Sun of the earth the
slower the flow of our proper time at
the surface of the earth for example if
we compare the internal clocks of two
observers one being at the base and the
other at the top of the Eiffel Tower we
would see that the internal clock of the
person at the bottom is slightly slower
since this person is closer to the
center of the earth
typically for each year that goes by the
person at the bottom of the tower ages a
microsecond less than the person at the
top this time dilation effect is very
subtle but extremely important on earth
it is crucial to take it into account
when we design GPS satellites such that
we can ensure the synchronization of
their internal clocks to sum up general
relativity gives a comprehensive
framework to grasp the phenomenon of
gravitation where a massive object lies
in space-time
it distorts the geometry around it
curving straight lines in time and in
space which in turn leads to the
deviation of surrounding objects and
modifies their perception of time apart
from gravitation general relativity also
brings about a number of other
surprising consequences one of these is
the fact that space-time is not
distorted instantaneously just like a
fabric that we might poke if an object
appears out from nowhere its
gravitational influence would take some
time to spread progressively through
space and time curving the geometry of
the universe as it progresses always at
the speed of light
this particularity leads to the
existence of gravitational waves
phenomena of distortion of space and
time which propagate through the
universe at the speed of light these
gravitational waves are generated
light-years away from the earth by
cataclysmic events such as the fusion of
two black holes they pass through us
regularly slightly distorting our planet
and everything on it as they go by
finally this idea that our universe
might have a distorted geometry begs the
question of its shape at a larger scale
and fuels numerous imaginations such as
the possible existence of geometric
shortcuts through space and time still
very speculative at the moment which we
call wormholes
[Music]
you